we're in the middle of the worst cost
living crisis for decades and people are
really struggling just last week energy
bills went up by hundreds of pounds and
today the government chooses to increase
tax on working people and this isn't the
first rise from this chance we've had 15
tax rises if you can believe it from
this chancellor so we've now got the
highest rate of taxation for 70 years so
this i'm afraid it's the wrong tax at
the wrong time and it's hitting lots of
working people and it's hitting
businesses and here at bay cup this
morning i've heard of a business that
says because of the energy bills because
of this tax rise they now won't be
taking on extra staff that's the human
cost of this failure by the government
well it's very important that we deal
with the backlog of cases in the nhs and
the labor government would always
support the nhs the problem i have with
this tax today
is that the money it will raise will
almost certainly be used to fill the
black hole because we've had over 11
billion pounds worth of fraud and loss
through covid related payments over the
last two years and the government's not
even trying to get that money back so
nobody's got a problem with money going
to the nhs this money sadly will be
paying off the incompetence and failure
of the government
in relation to fraud and equipment that
they never used during covert
it is really difficult for households at
the moment all of the prices are going
up whether that's fuel energy food
wages uh through the floor and i've
heard so many human stories
a pensioner with mobility problems was
talking to me about the fact that until
a very cold snap last week she hadn't
even had her central heating on because
she's so scared about the price and the
cost so many human stories um here in
bake up this morning business is saying
to me it's really impacting on them
they're feeling this extra tax
and then that results in them saying
we're not going to take on extra staff
so this is the wrong tax at the wrong
time
15 tax rises from this chancellor in two
years
highest taxation for 70 years this is a
government that because it hasn't grown
the economy has ended up as a high tax
government
conversion therapy in all its forms
should be banned
that used to be the government's
position
and they've been flip-flopping on this
over the last few days
they need to stick to their promises
but i can't help feeling that this is
yet more distraction tactics from the
government they know
that what is keeping people awake at
night is the cost of living where they
can pay their bills or not in order to
try and distract from that the
government wants to create an argument
about conversion therapy it's not going
to wash um we can all see what they're
up to
today is the day when most people are
worried about these new taxations the
government is imposing on them today
we need to have even tougher sanctions
in relation to what's happening in
ukraine we've all seen those
images those horrific harrowing images
coming out of ukraine we've all seen the
bravery and the courage of those
fighting in ukraine and we have to give
them every support we can that means
military support to help them defend
their cities and defend their countries
it means being absolutely clear and with
one voice that these war crimes and they
are war crimes will end up with those
responsible being hunted down everybody
is involved in these war crimes needs to
know they're not going to have
a night's sleep now until they're hunted
down and put before the international
criminal court so toughest sanctions
real effective uh remedies and we need
to stand together uh as in defense of
ukraine with our nato allies
i think we should have gone further and
i think we should have gone faster we
voted for the package that the
government put before
parliament
the government's talking about tougher
tank sanctions my message to the
government they stop talking about
tougher sanctions bring them forward and
i'll tell you what we won't divide on
this in parliament the labour party will
will support any further tougher
sanctions so if the government wants
tougher sanctions it knows what it needs
to do put a package for parliament we'll
vote for it it'll go through very
quickly and that's the right thing to do